i think a lot of dr falchi's kind of
undoing of public trust came in the
aftermath of the administration not so
much you know right when i was there um
because as you said we were all just
taking in the science at that point i
think as we've had time away from it we
can see okay wait he was no mask
then he was one mask then he was two
masks then don't mask if you're
vaccinated now back to one mask and we
can all know that that doesn't make
sense and then i was just very alarmed
when i see him have these exchanges with
rand paul
about uh gain of function research only
to find out in his emails he was talking
about gain of function research and you
know i'm paraphrasing and very broadly
summarizing it here he argues he was not
but i think as that came out and we
started to see some of those emails
all the pieces kind of fit together as
to who dr fauschi was um and it is and
he has some real questions to answer
about what he told congress
so i want to back up a little bit you
talked a little bit about kovid for just
a moment there but as everything was
starting to unfold which
in crazy i mean it's crazy to think
about basically two years ago at this
point we're two years into this can you
talk about what that was like at the
beginning as you guys are getting
information as fouchy's telling you
things as the cdc is telling you things
trump is you know saying close the
border with china they're calling him
racist just like the complete chaos of
like the first couple months
yeah it was total chaos because when i
showed up in the white house we were in
a nationwide lockdown i mean it was the
beginning oh right wait so you started
when in march or
yeah i started i think it was
technically april but yeah
got appointed but yeah april so yeah
nationwide lockdown it was uh kind of
jarring um certainly jarring and i can
tell you this like no one wanted to not
be in a lockdown more than president
trump the businessman it was literally
killing him having to do this um you
know you had someone who i think knew
how to handle and balance economic
interest and health interest i think he
did a great job and this president i
mean look at the vaccine mandate that
he's doing that's just killing american
businesses and de blasio tries to
outshine him by doing a stricter one um
you know it was it was definitely
strange to be in there i will say at
that time um but i i think the president
did a good job he doesn't get a lot of
credit for it i mean i was there and
jared kushner told me you know there's a
point where like we were scared you know
are there enough ventilators in this
country imagine the thought of having to
ration ventilators but the way that
jared kushner and president trump were
able to mobilize the private sector to
you know we not be so dependent on
foreign countries but mobilize it jump
start it to where we didn't have a
ventilator shortage we ended up getting
n95 masks and respirators and we were
able to
use a businessman and the ingenuity that
comes with that to escape some rather
scary scenarios that uh it's hard to
imagine it could be worse than the
number of people who have perished
already but i think it could have been
worse if not for the ingenuity of some
of the great people in the
administration did you have reservations
about fauci and the cdc and the nih and
everything like as they were first
giving you all the information because
if you look back two years ago everybody
myself included we were all listening at
the beginning like everybody was like
yes i'll wash my bags when i come home
from the supermarket and i'll put gloves
on when i go to costco like we all did
all of the stuff which in retrospect for
me at least seems completely ridiculous
at this point
yeah in retrospect um it does i mean i
think as you said when i first got in
there you know we had the coronavirus
task force led by vice president pence
and you know faulty would give his
opinion and dr burks and you know
everyone would give their opinion and
you're just trying to take in
information and consume as much as you
can so i think um you know for me early
on i was just taking in the information
and getting the words of doctors
comparing what azar was saying to berks
to falci to you know the different uh
people who had stakes in the game um fda
dr han but i mean i think it became
alarming to me when
dr fauci you know you'd get the media
lineup and this man would be on like
a thousand different things and like
facebooks and i'm like how does he have
time for science when he's literally
doing like a facebook live right now
with some person and i it just i i think
the uh level of media that that he was
doing and i i get that getting
scientific information out there to the
public is important and part of the job
but i don't think it should be all the
job and he was doing a whole lot of
media and um contradicting
different people in the administration
and it just kind of became a headache
what do you think we should think of him
at this point what do you make of him
i mean two years in it doesn't seem like
it's going that well
according to that
i will say i don't know that i was
shocked per se because i think a lot of
dr falchi's kind of
undoing of public trust came in the
aftermath of the administration not so
much you know right when i was there um
because as you said we were all just
taking in the science at that point i
think as we've had time away from it we
can see okay wait he was no mask then he
was one mask then he was two masks then
don't mask if you're vaccinated now back
to one mask and we can all know that
that doesn't make sense and then i was
just very alarmed when i see him have
these exchanges with rand paul
about gain of function research only to
find out in his emails he was talking
about gain of function research and you
know i'm paraphrasing and
very broadly summarizing it here he
argues he was not but i think as that
came out and we started to see some of
those emails
all the pieces kind of fit together as
to who dr fauci was um and it is and he
has some real questions to answer about
what he told congress do you think it
matters if you lie to congress anymore i
mean there's so many instances of
high-level people lying to congress
whether it's you know zuckerberg or
jacket twitter talking about shadow
banning or algorithmic tricks or
whatever else or
the former cia director we don't spy on
americans wittingly as he's scratching
his head because he knows he's lying or
fouchy with some of the gain of function
stuff like do you think it does does the
system function well enough to
to do anything if if you actually lie to
congress
well i mean in effect it matters if you
are a person on the right you know if
you're michael flynn and i talked about
his case a lot at the podium you know if
you're michael flynn the national
security advisor and the deep state
doesn't like how you operate they can
corner you in your office not tell you
to get a lawyer um and essentially try
to prosecute you and use a statute that
they've not used to prosecute anyone
before and it was the logan act i mean
this is just incredible stuff but if
you're dr fauci or several of the other
people you named uh then yeah it does
matter and it shouldn't there should be
one standard but uh yeah i mean
falsehoods that answered those questions
he argues it was not gain of function
research but um rand paul says it is
yeah all right so let's shift a little
bit to the book because the thai like
the title for a time such as this it's
like we are
living in extraordinary times uh you
know it's people think it's a chinese um
well it's a curse in essence may you
live in interesting times people think
that's a good thing but it's they sort
of mean it as a curse do you think we're
living in something that's
really unique that has that is different
than you know every other every four
years they tell us well this is the most
important four years it does seem like
something's a little different this time
around
something is very different i mean we
saw an entire country collapse that we
were in for two decades afghanistan
which is literally on the verge of
economic collapse as well i mean coven
19 never ending in the left seizing upon
it to have these
orwellian rules i mean we are in a very
different time in a polarizing time
where the right and the left um just
don't see uh the same set of facts even
it seems or have much in common uh to
say the least where you have the left
trying to destroy the american flag and
what our country stands for i do think
this is an aberrational time and
definitely when i went into the
administration you know i said for such
a time as this and a reference to the
book of esther because i went in during
a coven 19 pandemic just before the
murder of george floyd where riots took
over the nation i mean it was um
unexpected to say the least the
commander and the chief
commander-in-chief getting a novel
coronavirus pathogen i mean just story
after story and then a supreme court
justice passing just before a
presidential election and then amy coney
barrett coming in i mean this was a
crazy time i mean i believe i was put
there for a reason for purpose and my
dad said to me remember you're here for
such a time as this and then democrat
cnn commentator van jones texted me
separately that same message which i
thought was interesting and i was meant
to hear who by the way van is one of the
great democrats who's out there um
despite his political leanings he's just
a really decent and uh great person
yeah there's not many decent liberals
left
but i but i guess he's in that in that
small pool although i don't know him
personally so this is not an attack on
it personally but he still comes off
with this woke stuff and you're just
like
come on man you're supposed to be one of
the good ones i disagree with him on all
that but yeah
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell